dis moi alors il ya longtemps que j'ai
envie de te faire le questionnaire de
proust à eau qui c'est celui-là tu vas
voir
pour quelle faute à tulle le plus
d'indulgence celle de se faire [ __ ]
quel est ton personnage historique
favori parent a reculé quelconque yahia
paie pas à mettre qui jouent aux billes
bockel henri iii quoi quelle est ta
qualité préféré chez l'homme keath
passant qu'une un petit peu de temps en
temps chez la femme
aussi quelle pression préféré reculer
les gens qui aurais tu aimé être à noter
chez les amis ah qu'est ce que tu as
beau si le but c'était quelqu'un
principal défaut ne pas se faire en
tulle est-ce que tu détestes par
monsieur tous ceux qui soit pour le don
de la nature que tu voudrais avoir [ __ ]
comment aimerais tu mourir fois
la quel but de paul que c'est qu'elle
est de la devise ont tué aux ambulants
nous les uns les autres
ouais alors bon j'arrête oui a répondu
avec sérieux la question je vais te
poser maintenant on n'est pas dans le
questionnaire de proust
est ce qu'un tournage avec ce que tu
t'en vois quand même à moi là j'ai
restauré poli bah oui mais enfin
cigarettes et alcools quand même un
dakar est ce que tu as besoin
d'accessoires de michel maes est décédé
je n'aime pas tellement non je n'aime
pas mal venu nicher c'est un petit peu
comme une poupée que je formate petite
fille charlotte
ouais non mais demain je vais ouvrir un
godemiché ouais mais j'ai pas livré
comme ça j'aime et je lui pendent aux
yeux du rouge à lèvres c'est sûr qu'avec
des poupées mon petit chéri ne croit pas
si bien dire regarde regarde celui là